the energy of the audience
it's it's so alive i mean we do a lot of
outdoor concerts of course various
festivals but there's a certain
intense energy um
that's always been that way at cma fest
it's just and this year i think it's
amplified by the fact it hasn't been
here for two years and it feels like
everybody's been
dying to get back into this environment
and get that feeling back again
i mean does it feel special to you
because you know you came here to
nashville as a fan of country music you
know like you know what it's like to be
sitting in those stands too
yeah and i've also seen many concerts
here um so i know what it feels like to
be wherever people are sitting i've sat
all over the place here at the stadium
and getting to see this many artists in
one place is
incredible well when i get on stage i
hope it's good um we haven't seen these
guys in a couple years so uh you know i
think everybody's gonna be excited to be
here and obviously you know i've seen a
fest back it's been a couple years so
um
if if how us the artists feel is any
indication then i i expect it to be
a pretty wild and a good time the
weather's great usually that's kind of
hit or miss here so the weather's gonna
be perfect tonight and uh should be
great i think it's so great that there's
such a variety of
artists out there and reflecting a lot
of fans with genre music you know it's
um it's important in the country music
these days you can find
any music you want you know if you want
to listen to traditional country music
it's out there in so many different ways
right it's not just on your radio
anymore you can get it anywhere so i've
always felt like this genre music has
a tent big enough for everyone to live
underneath there's room for all of us in
here and it's fun for me being at this
point in my career to see what the kids
are doing and what's happening and all
the new people coming in not just um the
singers but journalists as well and
everyone it's just like yes let's bring
it in and mix it up and
and make it reflective of a lot of our
audiences that are out there and it's so
cma's doing a great job